[Musik]
Minuten Murat ernsthaft herzlich
willkommen zum Murat 5 Minuten heute
leider alleine die Königsteiner wieder
krank der Arbeit
deswegen soll ich da aber heute mache
ich zwei verschiedene Blätterteig
Rezepte mit denen ja mit denen Ihr
richtig cool Eindruck schicken könnt
entweder für euren Schwiegereltern oder
vor euren Freunden oder vielleicht habt
ihr auch ein cooles Date und ich möchte
zeigen dass ihr euch auch ein bisschen
was backen können meine Frau würde sich
für schämen das Rezept zu machen ich
schäme mich nicht dafür meine
schaumgrenze ist sehr sehr niedrig
deswegen mache ich das mit diesen
einfachen Zutaten und zwar habe ich hier
einen einfachen Blätterteig und fertig
Blätterteig dann habe ich hier
Kinderriegel aber wir können auch andere
Sachen nämlich keine produktplatz nimmt
irgendwas was ihr wollt es ist wirklich
kein Ding ich mag in der Regel einfach
so dann haben wir hier noch ein bisschen
Kuvertüre
und zwei Eier ja mehr braucht ihr
eigentlich wirklich nicht um dieses
tolle Rezept zu machen und richtig
Eindruck zu stehen den Blätterteig jetzt
einfach nur ausrollen ganz ganz easy
ziemlich diese Kinderriegel
das mache auszupacken
könnte aber wie gesagt wirklich alles
hin ihr könnt auch bueno nennen oder
irgendwas anderes was euch einfach
schmeckt oder vielleicht gerade was im
Angebot ist ihr könnt auch die gefakten
Dinger nehmen das ist auch völlig egal
macht was ihr wollt ihr könnt auch nicht
Schokolade nehmen auch kein Thema so ein
bisschen auseinander so so
nachdem sie ausgepackt habe einfach
so mit Augenmaß gerade runterschneiden
und jetzt einfach ein bisschen einrollen
[Musik]
so jetzt sind wir euer Backblech
Backpapier
und jetzt dreht ihr es rum und legt es
einfach auf den Button
[Musik]
so fertig
so jetzt ganz wichtig ich muss ein Ei
trennen
dafür braucht ihr diese zwei Eier
so
jetzt kommen ganz cooler Trick
faul darf sein aber nicht dumm
okay
[Musik]
unglaublich wie es geklappt hat und man
lernt wirklich niemals aus so jetzt sind
das Ei hier und tun einfach
die Taschen hier bestreichen
[Musik]
das war schon und jetzt einfach in den
vorgeheizten Backofen auf 180 Grad unter
Oberhitze ungefähr 20 bis 25 Minuten
reinstellen
wow so sieht es aus
und jetzt einfach ungefähr zehn Minuten
abkühlen lassen in der Zeit tun wir
schon mal die Schokolade schmelzen und
zwar machen wir oben so ein richtig
coolen wie so ein Trip drauf dazu haben
wir die Kuvertüre wenn ihr keine
kuvertür zu Hause habt könnt ihr auch
ausnahmsweise mal einfach eine Tafel
Schokolade nehmen und einfach im
Wasserbad schmelzen Wasserbad ganz ganz
einfach nimmt einen Topf mit Wasser und
tut diese schmelzschale drüberlegen die
Kuvertüre in diese schmelzschale
und der Dampf von dem ganzen Wasser tut
es einfach schmelzen
[Musik]
so jetzt ist fertig
schon ganz ganz easy sieht aus wie
frisch vom Bäcker wirklich ganz ganz
cool jetzt kommt die Alex zum Probieren
alex ist unsere
Alex jetzt probier's mal okay
schnell muss ich ganz ganz ehrlich sagen
es sieht voll krass aus was da gemacht
habe ich glaube
sehr lecker
Mädchen die die 20 Backzeit nicht
gewesen wäre ohne Spaß vielleicht 7
Minuten so das war das erste Rezept und
jetzt kommt noch eins wird so ähnlich
aber genauso schnell okay
ich warte mal ich brauche einfach
weiter okay weiter dafür benötigt ihr
einfach 250 Gramm Magerquark
ein Ei
50g Zucker eine Packung
Vanillepuddingpulver
backtrennspray zum einfetten von der
Backform und hier einfach nur ein
Blätterteig jetzt sind wir einfach den
Quark
also zuerst die flüssigen Zutaten und
ins richtig gut verrühren dafür könnt
ihr auch ein handrühren nehmen und
einfach schön rühren
bis es eine richtig das ist mir so
griesig ist sondern ein richtig coole
homogene Masse eine richtig coole Creme
ist so jetzt machen wir den Zucker rein
so
schön rühren und jetzt
Vanillepuddingpulver rein
boah das riecht schon richtig vanillig
aber ich möchte so ein bisschen
vanilliger haben
manchmal ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt
rein
so okay mal bisschen übertrieben
oh Gott Tonkabohnen liebe ich auch noch
ein bisschen auch noch rein ich könnte
da rein machen was ihr wollt jawohl ist
ein Tonkabohne so
und rühren und rühren
so
jetzt probiere ich mal ein bisschen
abschmecken
so
das war's und jetzt tun wir den
Blätterteig ausrollen
[Musik]
ihr müsst euch auch nicht dafür schämen
das in fertigen Blätterteig nimmt ich
meine es mir jetzt ich meine Freundin
mir doch selber gemacht aber einfach ein
fertigen Blätterteig und jetzt nehmen
wir die Creme und tun die Creme richtig
schön da drauf verstreichen das wird so
richtig geniale
Vanillepudding Blätterteigtaschen
so
und jetzt einfach richtig cool
verstreichen
jetzt nehme ich das bisschen auf
türkisch übrigens Fahrrad das kann man
einstellen das ist ein das braucht man
eigentlich wirklich zu Hause ist ein
ganz ganz cooles Tool was man immer
wieder benötigt und jetzt mache ich
einfach Streifen
so und jetzt
die cremige Angelegenheit
[Musik]
so jetzt nicht so cool aus und jetzt
nehmen wir die Muffinform aus der
abgekupfert Serie und tun Sie einfach
ganz kurz noch mal
das ist ein Kokos Rapsöl das war schon
ein fetten so und jetzt legen wir sie
rein jetzt sehen sie mich klein auf aber
denkt aus denkt aber dran dass sie noch
ziemlich aufgewerden ist immer die
kleinen Scheißer und legen Sie einfach
rein
so jetzt tun wir die in den Backofen den
vorgeheizten Backofen
225 Grad ungefähr ist nach jedem
Backofen ist da anders ungefähr 20
Minuten einfach beobachten rein okay
[Musik]
ich zeige euch jetzt wirklich was
grandioses ich komme jetzt vor wie so
ein Teleshopping Kanal aber pass mal auf
was ich jetzt mache
nur zeigen wie einfach die aus der Form
rausgehen okay
oh mein Gott
zack
krass oder wie einfach die aus dem
Formen rausgekommen sind okay jetzt
bevor die Alex kommt drehe ich sie alle
rum weil das ist cool aussieht
Hütchenspieler so jetzt holen wir die
Alex unsere Werkstudentin und probiert
es weitere Rezepte
hi Alex folgendes Pudding Taschen okay
der Hitmeister
oder was das auch cool kommt mit
Zuckerglasur ein bisschen Zitrone und
dann oben drüber
da kommt es noch
ein bisschen süße wirklich aber cool
oder also
okay ich hole noch cool
so
alles besorgt es geht auch Ratz
Fahrzeuge ich brauche nur einen Löffel
Alex wirklich nur kurz ein Löffel so die
Zitrone ganz wichtig vom auspressen kurz
mal
drücken okay so dann tun wir die
aufschneiden
[Musik]
das muss jetzt natürlich schnell gehen
Alex
wir wollen jetzt sag sag mal hier
drüber so
[Musik]
jetzt kommen Pinsel
okay
jetzt können wir nur was machen jetzt
können wir noch mal eine
Schokoladenglasur drüber
Hammer cool zwei ganz ganz einfach
schneller Rezepte was du begeistert
wirklich
nein alles klar also haut rein das war
ganz ganz zwei einfache Rezepte mit ganz
einfachen Zutaten günstig noch ebenfalls
dazu also richtig cool bleibt dran bei
moratz 5 Minuten
zu haben also macht's gut macht's besser
ihr macht vor allem bis dann tschüss
ciao
[Musik]